Neben den unendlichen und unerforschten weiten der ozeane sind
die alten ägyptischen pyramiden wohl das
Geheimnisvollste was unsere erde zu bieten hat noch heute sind so viele kuriose rätsel um die pyramiden ungelöst und bringen forschungsteams
Weltweit um den schlaf die entschlüsselung der pyramiden von gizeh ist nicht zuletzt so komplex
weil der älteste erhaltene bericht über die ganze zwei jahrtausende nach ihrem bau entstand geheimnisvolle energiefelder im inneren
Preußische liefen und zerbrochene sphinx nasen, ihr habt euch das thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt bei klicks um science fiction
Die acht spannendsten und kuriosesten pyramiden fakten herzlich willkommen
Auf der acht zerstörte oberlies, die nase der sphinx, naja, dies erkennt sie bestimmt alle diebe vacherin der pyramiden von gizeh
Charakteristisch ist ihre abgebrochene nase in dem asterix und obelix comic asterix und kleopatra von
1963 war es der gallier obelix
Der diese beim klettern zerstörte aus versehen teams von historikerinnen und historiker haben eine andere theorie
Demnach hat ein muslimischer bilderstürmer im vierzehnten jahrhundert
Die nase in voller absicht zerstört sie
Was hat es mit der geheimnisvollen pyramiden energie auf sich ein thema?
Was besonders diskutiert wird und ihr habt sicher alle schon einmal davon gehört es geht um die pyramiden energie demnach sollen
Pyramidenförmige gebäude oder auch ein behälter einen krassen einfluss auf die darin enthaltenen objekte haben
beispielsweise sollen stumpfe rasierklingen wieder scharf werden und lebensmittel dank, der
Mumifizierung länger haltbar seien seriöse wissenschaftliche experimente haben, aber bereits mehrmals das gegenteil gezeigt
der mythos der
Pyramiden energie, jedenfalls ist entzaubert
Naja, aber es gibt ja noch genügend andere die sechs auch vom weltraum aus zu sehen
Die pyramiden von gizeh in der nähe der ägyptischen stadt kairo sind mit ihren 4500 jahren nicht nur das älteste
Weltwunder der antike, sondern auch ein weltkulturerbe der unesco
Im gegensatz zur chinesischen mauer sind sie sogar von
Weltraumstationen aus ziemlich deutlich zu erkennen 5 gebaut von den preußen
Vielleicht habt ihr schon mal von den hieroglyphen recht über dem ursprünglichen eingang der cheops-pyramide gehört zitat so sprechen
Die jeder des königs namen sonne und fels preußen ist ja zitat ende haben, also vielleicht kann nicht die alten ägypter
Sondern die preußen, die hände im spiel
Eindeutig, nein, die hieroglyphen stammen von dem forscher karl richard lepsius
Der damit dem preußischen könig
Friedrich wilhelm dem vierten zum geburtstag gratulierte seine glückwünsche hat er einfach in die pyramide gemeißelt heutzutage
Wäre das undenkbar und die vier tausende weiterer pyramiden weltweit schätzungen
Zufolge gibt es neben, den alten ägyptischen pyramiden und den pyramiden der mayas in südamerika wohl noch hunderte weitere auf der welt vielleicht sogar tausende
Beispielsweise wurden weitere pyramiden auf den kanarischen inseln in arabien auf den malediven auf dem grund des atlantischen ozeans
Und in tibet entdeckt
Die meisten von ihnen sind aber wohl noch unentdeckt und befinden sich unter der meeresoberfläche in verlassenen dschungeln, oder unter dem eis der antarktis
Und dann auch oft natürlich natürlichen ursprungs
Denn die form der pyramide ist keine besonders komplexe und kommt oft auch ganz natürlich vor drei bau der pyramiden ein
Unlösbares rätsel stellt euch das mal vor die pyramiden sind mehr als 4500 jahre alt und damit das einzige
Weltwunder, der antike das sehr tausende überdauert hat und trotzdem gibt ihr bau forschungsteams weltweit große rätsel auf fest steht nur es sind bau
Technisch gesehen vollkommene meisterleistung doch, wie genau wurde sie gebaut
Es gibt vermutungen nach denen beim bau der cheops pyramide von der westlichen seite her eine lange rampe
Genutzt wurde darüber wurden
Dann vielleicht die 50 tonnen schweren deck blöcke für die grabkammer transportiert im oberen bereich wurden theorien zur folge
Spiral rampen genutzt in antiken berichten ist von hebel kennen, die rede eventuell wurden
die steinblöcke direkt an der pyramide aber auch mit winden hochgezogen, wie ihr seht, es gibt viele theorien, aber
Eindeutige beweise fehlen auf der zwei bedroht von luftverschmutzung und wüstensand, ich habe schon erwähnt, die pyramiden von gizeh sind, ja
4500 jahre alt und so lang hat sie eigentlich nichts erschüttern können, so wurde über jahrhundert hinweg
Der weiße kalkstein geplündert mit dem die pyramiden verkleidet
Waren doch die bedrohung heutzutage ist eine andere zum einen lagen der wüstensand und die luftverschmutzung an der substanz
Zudem setzten die vielen besucher und die resultierende feuchtigkeit im inneren zu aber vor allem das wachstum
Der stadt kairo ist laut unesco welterbe komitee eine große bedrohung für die vermieden
Dass problemmüll wird abgelagert und verbrannt und die regierung will eine verkehrsachse bauen damals noch standen die pyramiden frei
Mittlerweile werden sie von der stadt von drei seiten um schloss
Expertinnen und experten fordern eine pufferzone damit die pyramiden auch die nächsten jahre überstehen und last but not least
Die einst für am ideologie grenz wissenschaftliche theorien, omas, er wisse selbst
Um die pyramiden ranken sich unzählige mythen und nicht nur renommierte
Forschungsinstitute beschäftigen sich mit dem thema
Sondern auch die so genannten pyramide logan diese theorien rund um die pyramiden des alten ägyptens sind pseudo und grenz
Wissenschaftlich ihre anhänger nehmen beispielsweise
An, dass die pyramiden exakt so angeordnet wurden, dass sie dem sternbild orion entsprechen
Die maße der pyramiden richte sich nach der kreiszahl pi und dies spreche für eine höhere macht
Auf jeden fall wird dort immer wieder neues entdeckt
Wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema pyramiden pharaonen und die alten ägypter und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
Dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp, dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert
Ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion vom krieg so mitmachen und es gibt zu beginn auch ein kleines goodie
Wenn er darauf klingt, also hier draufklicken, der direkte draht zu mir und
Natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Schwimmer in der glocke vergessen, und hier geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken geheime kammer der cheops-pyramide entdeckt ansonsten. Bis dann
Bleibt dran?